the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright let's get started everyone so
good afternoon welcome to the second
lecture of six triple zero one and also
of 600 so as always if you'd like to
follow along with the lecture with the
lectures please go ahead and download
the slides and the code that that I'll
provide at least an hour before class
every day alright so quick recap of what
we did last time so last time we talked
a little bit about what a computer is
and I think the main takeaway from the
last lecture is really that a computer
only does what it is told right so it's
not going to spontaneously spontaneously
make decisions on its own you as the
programmer have to tell it what you want
it to do by writing programs okay so we
talked about simple objects and these
objects were of different types so we
saw integers floats and boolean's and
then we did a couple of simple
operations with them today we're going
to look at a different a new a new type
of object called a string and then we're
going to introduce some more powerful
things in our programming toolbox so
we're going to look at how to how to
branch within a program and how to make
things how to make the computer repeat
certain tasks within our program all
right so let's begin by looking at
strings so strings are a new object type
we've seen so far integers which were
whole numbers floats which were decimal
numbers and we have seen we've see
billions which were true and false
so strings are going to be sequences of
characters and these characters can be
anything they could be letters digits
special characters and also spaces and
you tell Python that you're you're
talking about a string object by
enclosing it in quotation marks so in
this case I'm creating an object whose
value is h-e-l-l-o space th er E and
Python knows it's a string object
because we're enclosing it in quotations
they could be either double quotes or
single quotes but as long as you're
consistent it doesn't matter
and this object worse where we're
binding it to this variable named hi and
we're using that using the equal sign
which is the assignment operator okay so
from now on whenever we refer to this
variable hi python is going to say oh i
know what the value is and it's that
string of characters so we're going to
learn about two things that you can do
on strings today two operations one is
to concatenate them and concatenation is
really just a fancy word for using this
plus operator which means put the
strings together so I have this original
variable named hi and I create a new
variable called name and in it I'm going
to assign I'm going to assign the string
a na to the variable name and when I use
the plus operator in between high and
named those two variables Python is
going to look at the values of those two
and it's going to just put them together
okay I'm going to switch to Sky to
spider and this is just that example
from the from the slides so let's see
what happens so I have the variable hi
the variable name and I'm just
concatenate again and then I'm going to
print that out so if I run the code
notice it prints out hello there Anna
right there's no space and there's no
space because the concatenation up
operator the plus doesn't add any spaces
implicitly so again another example of
just computer just doing what it's told
if we want to add a space we'd have to
actually insert the space manually so
that's this line here line 8 and in this
line we're concatenating the very value
of the variable high with a space notice
we're putting it in quotation marks just
the space and then with name so if we go
ahead and print that value notice this
was that garbage greeting there and now
we have a proper greeting right
another so that's the concatenation
between strings and then the other thing
we're going to look at related to
strings is the star operator so that's
this one here on line 10 so python
allows you to use the star operator
which is stands for multiplication
between a string and a number and when
you do that python interpreter
interprets it as repeat that string that
many number of times so in this case I'm
creating a silly greeting and I'm
concatenated the value of hi which is
hello there with the space plus the name
so notice here I'm using parentheses to
tell Python do this operation first and
then multiply whatever the result of
this is by 3 okay so if I print that out
it's going to multiply the space with my
name three times and it's going to
concatenate that with hello there so
that's exactly what it printed out there
last lecture we talked a little bit
about about print today I'm going to
talk about about some nuances related to
print so you use print to interact with
the user it's cool to write programs
that print things out to the user so the
keyword here being print and then you
put parentheses after print and in the
parentheses you put in whatever you want
to show the user so in this little
program I have I create a variable named
X I assign it the value 1 and then I
print one here I'm casting so I'm taking
the number one the integer one and I'm
casting it to a string and you'll see
why in a moment so I want to bring to
your attention a couple things here so
in the first print I'm using commas
everywhere here and then the second
print I'm using plus
so by definition if you can use print
you can use commas inside a print inside
the parentheses of print and if you use
a comma Python is going to automatically
add a space in between the two things
that the commas in in between the values
so my fav num is is the first thing and
the second thing is whatever is after
the comma
let's take X so if you use a comma
Python is going to automatically insert
a space for you okay sometimes you might
want that sometimes you might not if you
don't want that you can use the
concatenation operation the plus and you
can add all of your little bits together
to create one big string if you're using
commas the items the objects in between
the commas do not all have to be strings
that's the plus side of using commas but
the downside is you get spaces
everywhere if you use plus operator the
plus side is Python does exactly what
you tell it to do but everything has to
be a string object so my fav num is is a
string object you have to convert all of
your numbers to string objects and so on
so if we look at spider
this is the same almost the same code so
here I don't have spaces anywhere so you
can see that the first line here has
commas everywhere so I'm going to have
spaces in between every one of the
things that I'm that I'm printing out
this line here is sort of a combination
between commas and concatenation so
depending on where I use the comma I'm
going to have an extra space and this
line here just has concatenation
everywhere
okay so if I run this notice this very
first line added spaces everywhere in
between all my objects the second one
added spaces somewhere and you can sort
of trace through and see exactly where
the spaces were added and the last line
here didn't add spaces anywhere
okay
so printing things out to the console is
nice but the second part of sort of
writing an interactive program is
getting input from the user and that's
that's a more interesting part so if
you've done problem set 0 you might have
sort of already tried to understand this
on your own but here we are so the way
you get input from the user is using
this command function called input and
inside the parentheses you type in
whatever you'd like to prompt the user
with so in this case in my example here
I have input and then here I said type
anything so the user is going to see
this text here and then the program is
just going to stop and it's going to
wait for the user to type in something
and hit enter as soon as the user types
in enter whatever the user types in
becomes a string okay if the user types
in a number for example that becomes the
string that number okay so everything
that user types in is going to be made
as a string in this line right here
whatever the user types in becomes a
string and we're going to bind that
string object to this variable named
called text okay so now further in my
program I could do whatever I want with
this variable text in this case I'm
going to print 5 start text okay
so if the user for example gave me ha
I'm going to print ha 5 times if the
user gave me 5 what do you think the
users what do you think's going to be
printed out 25 or 5 5 times great
yes exactly 5 5 times
often times you don't want to work with
numbers as strings right you want to
work with numbers as numbers right so
you have to cast and we learn that last
lecture you cast by just putting in this
little bit right in front of the input
and you can cast it to whatever type you
want here I cast it to an int but you
can also cast to a float if you want to
work with floats and that converts
whatever the user typed in as long as
it's some number that Python knows how
to how to convert into the number itself
so in this case if the user gives me
five I'm going to print out five times
five instead of five five times so
that's the code here so the first bit is
I'm going to get the user to type in
anything and I'm going to put five five
five and then when I type in the number
since I'm casting it I'm going to do
operations with the number yeah question
why do you want to cast - oh the
question is why do you want to cast - a
string what why do you want to cast a
string to a number Oh so Python always
whatever you whatever you type in just
by default by definition of the input
command Python always makes it a string
so if you want to work with numbers you
have to explicitly tell it I'm going to
work with a number so even if you give
it the number five it's going to think
it's the string five yeah that's just
how input works
the next thing we're going to look at is
ways that you can start adding tests in
your code and before you can start
adding tests before you can start adding
tests in your code you need to be able
to do the actual tests
so this is where comparison operators
come in okay
so here let's assume that I and J are
variables okay the following comparisons
are going to give you a boolean so it's
either going to say this is true or this
is false so that's going to be your test
so if I and J are variables you're
allowed to compare in swith int floats
with floats strings with strings and
you're allowed to compare instant floats
between themselves but you're not
allowed to compare a string with a
number in fact if you even try to do
that in Python in spider here if I try
to say is the letter A greater than 5 I
get some angry text right right here and
this just tells me Python doesn't
understand the meaning of what how do I
compare a string with a number right
okay so just like in math we can do
these usual comparisons we can say if
something is greater than something
greater or equal to less than less than
or equal to I'd like to bring to your
attention the Equality so the single
equal sign is an assignment so you're
taking a value and you're signing it to
a variable but when you're doing the
double equal sign this is the test for
equality is the value of variable I the
same as the value of the variable J okay
and that's again also going to give you
a boolean either true or false and you
can also test for inequality with the
exclamation equal so that means is the
value of the variable I not equal to the
value of the variable J true if yes
false if no okay so those are comparison
operators on integer floats and strings
on bullying's you can do some logic
operators
and the simplest is just inverting so if
a is a vet is a variable that can that
has a boolean value not a is just going
to invert it so if it is true then not a
is false and vice versa this is a table
that sort of represents what I've said
here so you can do you can use and and
or these are keywords in Python you can
use those two keywords on variables on
boolean variables and you get the result
and B is only true if both a and B are
true and a or B is only false if a and B
are false and this is the complete table
just in case you need to reference it
alright so now that we have ways to do
logical tête that question right there
yeah great question so what does it mean
to compare a string with a string with
the greater than so that's just going to
compare them like psychographically
so it does it come first in the alphabet
so we can even test that out we can say
is a greater than B and it's false so B
becomes later in the alphabet than a
so now we have ways to do the tests so
we can add some branching to our
programming toolbox now that we have
ways to do tests okay this is a map of
MIT I'm going to go through sort of a
little example to motivate why we would
want to do branching in our in our in
our code and I think after this lecture
you'll be able to sort of code up this
algorithm that I'm going to explain so
most of us see MIT as a maze I first did
when I came here when I first came here
obviously I signed up for the free food
mailing list and MIT being amazed I had
no idea where to go right what the
shortest path was to free food so one
way to think about it is all I wanted to
do was get to the free food a very
simple algorithm to get there would be
to say okay I'm going to take my right
hand and I'm going to make sure that my
right hand is always on a wall okay and
I'm going to go around campus with my
right hand always being at a wall and
eventually I'll get to the where the
free food is I might not there might not
be any left right but I'll be there okay
so the algorithm is as follows okay if
my right hand always has to be on a wall
then I'm going to say if there's no wall
to my right side then I'm going to go
right until I get to a wall okay then if
there's a wall to my right and I can go
forward I'm just going to keep going
forward okay if I keep going forward and
there's a wall to my right and in front
of me I'm going to turn around and go
left okay and then if there's a wall to
my right in front of me and to the left
that I'm going to turn around and go
back
so with this fairly simple algorithm I
just follow the the path always keeping
the wall to my right and eventually I
wind up where I need to be okay so
notice I used just in plain English a
few key words okay if otherwise things
like that
so in programming we have those same
constructs and those same sort of
intuitive words can be used to tell
Python to do
thing or to do something else or to
choose from a different set of
possibilities okay and this way we can
get the computer to make decisions for
us now you might be thinking well you
said that computers can't make decisions
on their own it's not us programmers are
going to build these decisions into the
program and all the computer is going to
do is going to say is going to reach the
decision point and say okay this is a
decision point should I go left or
should I go right or which one do I pick
and these sort of decisions are created
by you as the programmer and the
computer just has to make make the
decision and choose a path okay so in
programming there's three sort of simple
ways that you can add control flow to
your programs and that's making one
decision and choosing whether to execute
something or execute something else the
first is a simple if okay and given a
program that just linearly has
statements that get executed whenever I
reach an if statement you're going to
check the condition the condition is
going to be something that's going to
get evaluated to either true or false
okay so I've reached the condition here
and if the condition is true then I'm
going to additionally execute this extra
set of expressions but if the condition
is false then I'm just going to keep
going through the program and not
execute that extra set of instructions
okay how does Python know which
instructions to execute they're going to
be inside this what we call code block
and the code block is denoted by
indentation so it's going to be
everything that's indented is part of
that if code block typically four spaces
indentation okay so that's
that's how you'd write code that decides
whether to execute this extra thing or
not now let's say I don't just want to
execute an extra thing I want to reach a
condition I want to reach a point where
I say I'll either go down this path or
I'll do something else okay
that's this right here so this if/else
construct says this is my code I've
reached my decision point here if the
condition inside this if is true then
I'm going to execute maybe this set of
statements here okay but if the
condition is not true then I'm not going
to execute that set of statements and
instead I'm going to execute under
whatever else is so using this construct
I'm either going to do one set of
expressions or the other but never both
okay
and after I've executed one or the other
I'm going to continue on with just the
regular execution of the program all
right
okay so we're able to either choose one
thing choose one thing or another but
what if we want to have more than one
choice so if some number is equal to
zero I want to do this if it's equal to
one I want to do this otherwise if it's
equal to two I want to do this and so on
that's where this last one comes in and
we introduced this other keyword here
called Elif so that stands for short
form for else--if so first we check if
this condition is true so we're going
through our program we've reached our
decision point if the condition is true
we're going to execute maybe this set of
instructions if the conditions not true
maybe we'll check what if the condition
is not true we will check this next
condition that's part of the L if right
here and if that one's true we're going
to execute a different set of
instruction
you can have more than one L if and
depending on which one's true you're
going to execute a different instead of
instructions and then this last else is
sort of a catch-all where if none of the
previous conditions were true then just
do this this last set of expressions so
in this case you're going to choose
between one of these three one of these
four routes or however many you have and
then when you're done making your choice
you're going to execute the remaining
set of instructions so the way this
works is if more than one condition is
true you're actually just going to enter
one of them and you're going to enter
the very first one that's true so you're
never going to enter more than one of
these code blocks you're always enter
one and you enter the very the first one
that's that evaluates to true so notice
that we denoted code blocks using
indentation and that's actually one of
the things that I really like about
Python it sort of forces you to write
pretty code and nice-looking code and
just code that's very readable and that
it forces you to indent everything
that's a code block okay so you can
easily see sort of where the flow of
control is and where decision-making
points are and and things like that okay
so in this particular example we have
one if statement here and it checks if
two variables are equal and we have an
if L if else
and in this example we're going to enter
either this code block or this one or
this one depending on the variables of X
and Y and we're only going to enter one
code block and we'll enter the first one
that that's true
notice you can have nested conditionals
so inside this first if we have another
if here and this inner if is only going
to be checked when we enter the first
this outer if
okay I do want to make one point though
so sometimes you might forget to do the
double equals sign when you do when you
check Warren you're checking for
equality and that's okay if you just use
one equal sign pythons going to give you
an error and it's going to say syntax
error and it's going to highlight this
line and then you're going to know that
there's there's a there's a mistake
there you should be using equality
because it doesn't make sense to be
using to assign to be making an
assignment inside the if okay all right
so we've learned about branching and we
know about conditionals let's try to
apply this to to a little game and
spoiler we won't be able to we'll have
to learn about a new thing but back in
1980s there was the Legend of Zelda cool
graphics where there was a scene with
the Lost Woods okay oversimplification
if anyone's a Zelda know die-hard fan
but the basic idea was if you entered
the woods you know you entered from the
left to the right and then as long as
you kept going right it would show you
the same screen over and over again okay
and the trick was you just had to go
backward and then you'd exit exit the
woods okay so very simple using what we
know so far we could sort of code this
up and we'd say something like this if
the user exits right then set the
background to the woods background
otherwise set the background to the exit
background okay now let's say the user
and then and then in the else we're done
let's say the user went right well you'd
show them the woods background and now
ask them again where do they want to go
if they exit right set the background to
the woods background otherwise set the
background to the exit background and so
on so you notice that there's sort of no
end to this right how many times do you
know do you know how many times the user
might keep going right they might be
really persistent right and they'll be
like maybe maybe if I go a thousand
times
get out of the woods you know maybe a
thousand one maybe so this this would
probably be who knows how deep this
nested does these nested ifs okay so we
don't know so with what we know so far
we can't really code this this cute
little game but enter loops and
specifically a while loop so this code
here that could be you know infinitely
number of nested if statements deep can
be rewritten using these three lines so
we say while the user exits right set
the background to the woods background
and with a while loop it's going to do
what we tell it to do inside the loop
and then it's going to check the
condition again and then it's going to
do what we what we say it should do
inside the code block and then it's
going to set the check the condition
again and then when the condition as
long as the condition is true it's going
to keep doing that little loop there and
as soon as the condition becomes false
it's going to stop doing the loop and do
whatever is right after the while okay
so that's basically how a while loop
works we have while that's the keyword
the condition is something that gets
evaluated to true or false and once
again we have a code block that's
indented and it tells Python these are
the expressions I want to do as long as
the condition is true so the condition
is true you evaluate every expression in
the code block when you reach the end of
the expression end of the code block you
check the condition again if it's true
still you keep doing the expressions
check it again and so on
so here's a little game and with these
lines of code we were able you know we
can code up the the lost losses of of
Zelda even worse graphics by the way
than the original Zelda is this one that
I coded up here so I print out the
following things you're in the last
forest go left or right and my program
is going to say you know you're in the
last forest go left or right it's going
to get user input it's going to say
while the user keeps typing in right
show them this text and ask them again
right so I'm asking them again by just
saying input here again and that's it
that's going to just keep getting input
from the user and if the user doesn't
type in right and maybe types in left
you're going to exit out of this loop
and print out you got out of the loss
force so I have to show you this because
I spent too much time on it but I
decided to improve on the code that's in
the slides and I've written here ways
that you guys can also improve it so if
I run my code you'll know you're in the
last force go left or right so if I say
left then yay I got out of the last
forest but if I go right then I'm stuck
right I took down some trees you can see
there's no more trees here I made a
table and then I flipped it over okay so
the expansion to this if you want to try
it out I put this in the comments here
is try to use a counter okay if the user
types and write the first two times just
make that a sad face but if the user
types in more than two times make them
cut down some trees and build a table
and flip it okay that's a cute little
expansion if you want to test yourself
to make sure you you're getting loops
okay so so far we've used while loops to
ask for user input and that's actually
somewhere where it makes sense to use
while loops because you don't actually
know how many times the user is going to
type in something you can use while
loops
to keep sort of a counter and to write
code that counts something if you do
that though there's two there's two
things you need to take care of the
first is this first line here which is
sort of an initialization of this loop
counter and the second is this line here
which is incrementing your loop counter
the reason why the second one is
important is because let's look at our
condition here so while n is less than
five if you didn't have this line here
you'd never increment n so every time
through the loop you just keep printing
zeros okay and you'd have an infinite
loop I do want to show though what if
you do have an infinite loop it's not
the end of the world so I can say
something like so while true print zero
okay so this is going to give me an
infinite loop in my program and
okay so notice it's just printing the
letter P over and over again and if I
let it go any longer it's going to slow
down the computer so I'm going to hit
control-c or command-c maybe and it's
going to stop the program from printing
okay
so just in case you ever enter enter
infinite loops in your programs just go
to the console and hit control-c and
that's going to stop it from sort of
slowing down the computer okay so going
back to this example I was saying that
if you're using counters or variables in
order to sort of count up inside the
while loop you have to take care to
initialize a counter variable first and
then to increment it otherwise you'll
enter an infinite loop that feels a
little bit tedious and so there's a
shortcut for doing that exact same thing
so these four lines you can rewrite
those into these two lines right here
using this new type of loop called a for
loop so the for loop says for some loop
variable in this case I named it n you
can name it whatever you want in range 5
we're going to come back to what range
means in a little bit print n okay so
every time through the loop you're going
to print out what the value of n is
range 5 actually creates internally a
sequence of numbers starting from 0 and
going to that number 5 minus 1 so the
sequence is going to be 0 1 2 3 and for
the first time through the loop you're
going to say n is equal to 0 or
internally this is what happens and gets
the value 0 you're going to print n then
you're going to back go back to the to
the top and gets the value 1 then you're
going to go execute whatever is inside
so you're going to print 1 then you're
going to increment that to the next
value in the sequence you're going to
print out 2 and so on so this is the
general look of a for loop so we have
for some loop variable again can be
named whatever you want in rain
change some number do a bunch of stuff
and again these are part of this four
loop code block so you should indent
them to tell Python that these are the
things that you should do okay so when
you're using range some number you start
out with variable getting the values
zero okay with with variable having
value zero you're going to execute all
of these expressions after all the
expressions in the code block are done
you're going to go on to the next value
so one you're going to execute all these
expressions with variable being value
one and then so on and so on until you
go to some num minus one that it's so so
using range in that way is a little bit
constraining because you're always going
to get values starting from zero and
ending at some numb - 1 ok whatever is
in the parentheses in range sometimes
you might want to write programs that
maybe start at a custom value don't
start at 0 maybe they start at 5
maybe start at minus 10 and sometimes
you might want to write programs that
don't go with don't increment the
numbers by 1 but maybe skip every other
number go every two numbers every three
numbers and so on so you can customize
range to your needs the one thing you do
need to give it is this stop so if you
give it only one value in the
parentheses that stands for stop and by
default start is going to have the value
0 and step is going to have the value 1
if you give it two things in the
parenthesis you're giving it start and
stop so the first thing start the second
being stop and step gets this value of 1
by default and if you give it 3 things
in the parenthesis you're giving it
start stop and step in that order
and you're always going to start at the
start value and stop at or so you're
going to start at the start value and
you're going to go until stop minus one
so those are the the sequences of
numbers so in this first code right here
my sum is going to get the value zero
and you're going to have a for loop
we're going to start from seven right
because we're giving it two numbers and
when you give it two numbers it
represents start and stop with step
being one so you're starting at seven if
step is one the next value is eight
what's the value after that if we're
incrementing by one nine and since we're
going until stop minus one we're not
actually going to pick up on ten okay so
this loop variable I the very first time
through the loop is going to have the
value seven so my sum is going to be
zero plus seven that's everything that's
inside the code block the next time
through the loop I gets the value eight
so inside inside the for loop my sum
gets whatever the previous value was
which was seven plus eight okay the next
time through the loop my sum gets the
value seven plus eight plus nine
obviously replacing that with the
previous value so fifteen okay since
we're not going through ten that's where
we stop and we're going to print out my
sum which is going to be the value of
seven plus eight plus nine
okay
okay yeah do they have to be integers um
that's a great question we can try that
out I'm not actually sure right off just
off the top of my head so you can go in
Spyder and say let's say in this example
here in this example here so we can say
seven point one ten point three yeah so
they have to be integers
okay so that's that's that example and
let's erase that in this particular
example we have start/stop and step and
here we're going going every other value
so we're starting at five tell me what
the next value is supposed to be if
we're taking every other one seven and
then nine and then are we doing 11 or
not excellent nice yeah so we're going
to the end minus one okay so it's
possible that sometimes you write code
where you might want to exit out of the
loop early okay you don't want to go
through all of the sequences of your
numbers maybe there's a condition inside
there where you just want to exit the
loop early inside the while loop maybe
you want to exit the loop before the
condition becomes false so that's where
the break statement comes in so the
break works like this it's going to as
soon as Python sees this break statement
it's going to say okay I'm going to look
at whatever loop I'm currently in I'm
not evaluating any expression after it
that comes within my loop and I'm going
to immediately exit the loop so I'm
going inside this while this while I'm
evaluating this one expression and I
suddenly see a break expression B does
not get evaluated and break is going to
immediately exit out of the innermost
loop that it's in so this while loop
that has condition - that's the
innermost loop that the break is found
its found in so we're going to exit out
of this innermost loop here and we're
evaluating expression C and notice we're
evaluating expressions C because its
expression C is part of the outer while
loop it's at the same level as this one
and these ones are part of the inner
while loop okay okay
last thing I want to say is just a
little bit of a comparison between for
and while loops so when would you use
one or the other this might be useful in
you
problem sets so for loops you usually
use when you know the number of
iterations okay while loops are very
useful when for example you're getting
user input and user input is
unpredictable right you don't know how
many times they're going to do a certain
task for both for and while loops you
can end out of the loop early using the
break the for loop uses this counter its
inherent inside the for loop a while
loop you can use a counter in order you
can use a while loop to count things but
you must initialize the counter before
the while loop and you have to remember
to increment it within the loop
otherwise you may be lead to an infinite
loop we've seen in as the very first
example of a for loop that the while
loop the for loop could be rewritten as
a while loop but the vice-versa is not
necessarily true and the counter example
to that is just user input so you might
not know how many times you might do a
certain task all right great that's
that's all for today